so i'll talk about actors and varying
cause of prediction experiment selection
through stability
and very recently i joined the health ai
team at apple but this work was done at
eth at the seminar for statistics
and this is joint work with a phd
student my co-supervisor juan gamaya
so the setting we're interested in here
is
learning the causal structure from data
or these parts of the causal structure
so in particular here we're interested
in a setting where we want to we're
interested in a particular target
variable y of interest
and we want to infer
which variables are the causal parents
of y in the underlying causal graph
and furthermore the setting we consider
here is where we have data from
so-called different environments or
domains available
and i get into what that means more
concretely
in
later in the talk
so even though learning parts of the
causes structure is our goal here let me
motivate the methodology more from a
prediction point of view and an
out of distribution generalization point
of view and that also sheds slight
light on uh why the methodology is
called invariant causes prediction
so in this example so i generate data
from the graph shown here on the right
so when we apply our method of course
the the graph is unknown
but i put it here since it's synthetic
we we also know the ground truth in this
example
so i generate data from it and then i
compare three different models where we
use some subset of the covariates to
predict y
and then what i plot in these graphs is
i plot the observations y and the y axis
and then the predictions we obtain for
these three different models on the
x-axis so good predictions means that
the points will lie
very close to the diagonal
so then what are the three models we
compare here so the first one is what we
call the causal model meaning that i
just use the causal parents of y to
predict y
so in this example this is
x2 and x3
and then the second one in the middle
that is what we call the full model
meaning i just use all available
covariates to predict why
and then the last one which here i call
n invariant model for reasons that will
become clear later
and here i just use
x2 as input
and so what we observe here in
this observation environment so there we
don't have any interventions on the
nodes in the system
that in fact the full model so fields
the best predictions
and then followed by the causal model
which also does
fairly well
and then the invariant model which in
this example is shows the worst
performance but i'd say is also not
entirely off either
so then what we what we do next so we
have now data from a different
environment available so i'll call this
the test environment
and in fact this is generated by
intervening on x2 and x4
in in this data generating mechanism so
i observe now data from this
interventional distribution
and now i just employ the models we
trained for on the observational data
and just see how they perform
in this test environment
and so what we observe is that the
causal model still performs very similar
to to the previous settings of the
training environment
whereas now the full model which was
sort of the best model in terms of
predictive accuracy previously
now uh performs uh much worse and and
one could say it really does not work
any longer
and then finally the invariant model so
again it performed similarly as before
but still worse than the causal model
[Music]
so what this example illustrates are the
two statements that are shown
at the top of the slides namely the
causal models generalize
and i should say here the underlying
assumption is when we go to these
different environments that we don't
intervene on y directly so the
underlying assumption is that the
data generating mechanism of y always
stays the same but potentially we could
intervene on all the other covariates
so in such setting you can take the
causal model to such a new environment
and it will continue to yield good
predictions
but we also observe that this is
not only true for the causal model
depending on what environments you see
right so here what i called an invariant
model for this environment also
continues to work even though in this
example it's maybe a bit worse than a
causal model but you could also have
settings where
a model that is not the cause model
actually gets better predictions than
than the causal model for some
particular environment
so
depending on what
environments you observe
what variations you see
you will generally have multiple models
that show this this generalization
so now what we observed is
actually very well known properties of
causal models
namely that
as long as we don't
intervene on y directly
then when we compare this
conditional distribution of y
conditioning on the true set of causal
parents
that distribution remains invariant
across
these environments
where these environments
are generated by interventions on the
remaining variables in the system
and in terms of notation so s star
denotes the causal appearance of y
throughout this talk
now this has been sort of known for a
very long time but then
what this method of invariant cause of
prediction
in that sense i exploited was to turn
this around initial sent
and say well maybe we can if we have
data from multiple environments
can we find
invariant conditional distribution
and use that to estimate a star in in
some way
but as i said before since
given some observed set of environments
there will often be multiple sets of
predictor variables or covariates
that satisfy this invariance we still
have to work a bit harder so this is not
only true for the for the cause of
parents as star
so
more generally so we will call these set
of variables uh that that satisfy this
invariance just so it's an invariant
set
under some set of observed environments
as script e
so then the method goes as follows so
given some observed environments
we will
somehow find all the invariant sets
and then
to get an estimate for a star we just
return the intersection of all the sets
that are invariant given my environments
and
like a small disclaimer so i'm
simplifying the terminology and the
notation a little bit i hope this does
not cause confusion for those of you who
who know this work a bit better but if
it does that please ask
major assumptions here are that you have
an a a cyclic underlying causal system
there are no hidden confounders and as i
already said no interventions on y
directly so for instance this would also
mean if you think of the structural
equation models then the structural
equation of y
that the noise in that structural
equation has the same distribution
across all environments
so then there are sort of different
works that sort of work out how you do
this part of the first steps how you
find all invariant sets
so the original paper by peters and all
looked at the linear setting and made
concrete proposals how you can do this
in a linear setting
then i worked on the nonlinear case and
it fixed it or worked on a sequential
time series setting
but all of these approaches are based on
statistical hypothesis testing
so for all of these settings you would
um design a statistical test where the
null hypothesis would correspond to sort
of invariance across environments
and then you would test there's no
hypothesis for all possible subsets of
the covariates
and then
now a bit more precisely
return the intersections of those sets
for which you could not reject the null
hypothesis
and so
to clarify this is set up in such a way
that this null hypothesis would hold for
the
true set of causal parents
for all possible sets of environments
but then for for some environments this
may also hold for for other sets as
and so one
nice property of this method is that it
has
the following guarantee
so you can show that the estimate you
get as hat is a subset of the true
causal parentheses star with high
probability
and this
comes from the fact that so we test this
null hypothesis for all possible subsets
of the predictors
so at some point we will test the true
set of causal parents
and then since we know that the null
hypothesis is true for both
we know that we don't reject with
probability larger than one minus alpha
where alpha would be the the
significance level of the associated
statistical test you used here
um
so this essentially means we have a
guarantee that the our estimate does not
um
give false positives high probability
and in some applications this is really
a feature because you can say okay the
result i get is in that sense we have
high confidence edges in in some sense
that we that we estimate here
but um on the other hand it also comes
at a
cost of lack of power let's say so when
you run this
given some set of observed environments
you also often may end up with the empty
set so then of course the statement is
still true
but the
the output in that sense is not very
informative so then it should not be
interpreted saying okay why does not
have any parents but it may as well mean
um well i don't have sort of enough
variety in my environments to detect the
cause of parents here
so in that sense it also has a
conservative method in the sense that it
sort of
depending on the environments the output
may be uninformative but if you do get a
non-empty set you can be pretty
confident that this is indeed a
causation of why
are there any results that give you
non-trivial power
are there any results that give you
non-trivial power for this um
i think not directly but what i will
talk about is
this active setting where you can
intervene in the system and that
essentially sort of then shows you how
sort of quickly you gain power or not
yeah
there's could be many different subsets
to search over this would be like a
multiple
yes so that sense is an expensive method
because you need to sort of give your
very little variance you need to check
all possible success
so we also affect your statistical kind
of
so the the thing is it only matters what
you do when you test the true positive
parents so the testing errors at the
other sets would not affect this
guarantee
so that's why if you just run this
on sort of once
um you don't need to adjust for for
multiple testing hours and the second
thing i'll talk about we actually do
have to adjust because we'll run the
methods um multiple times
anything else at this point
ah okay
so what i wanted to talk a bit more uh
in this talk is this this aspect of the
different environments and let me start
by giving you a sense of what the real
data sets that has this has been used on
so
this has been employed on a gene
perturbation experience for yeast where
as environments you take
wild type versus gene deletions
then in the context of non-linear icp
this has been
uh employed on a data set from the u.n
where the target variable of interest a
y is a total fertility rate of the
country and there's environments we
could use the different continents
and then
finally sort of also one fairly classic
application of causal structure learning
algorithm is this
data set from sex at all which is about
protein signaling network estimation
which is then based on a flow cytometry
data
and there the different environments are
different experimental conditions
that you can use
and i would say when you apply this in
practice sort of the results are
somewhat mixed in the sense that
sometimes you you do get like non-empty
sets and and then again we have sort of
this confidence that of course if our
assumptions are satisfied that that
these are now in fact like
cause apparents
but often you also get the get the empty
set as a result
so hence um we wanted to understand a
bit better sort of
what to say because the conditions on
these environments that maybe give you
give you more power and then concretely
if we say are in a setting where we can
directly intervene the system how should
we sort of perform interventions to to
improve the power of this method
and
so from the beginning um it was clear
that heterogeneity plays a key role and
the sort of hydrogen is good
but so we were then a bit more
concretely interested sort of what kind
of heterogeneity helps
so now for this purpose we
we focus on this setting that
active causal learning so we want to
learn the the causal structure but we
also assume that we are able to actively
perform interventions on the on the
covariates in the system
so
the we would always have these rounds
where we would
choose an intervention target then we
can say perform the experiment collect
the data from it
and then run
our causal discovery algorithm on on
this
newly created environment and the the
ones that were previously available
and this work we focus on on icps is
called a discovery algorithm
so
let us look at an example of how this
would go so here again i show the
underlying graph on the left but again
this is unknown when we when we run the
method
and then i plot
here just these uh
these
single predictors against y but again
the method internally would have to
consider all possible subsets
so when we start out with just one
environment some practice you would not
run icp was just one environment um
but in principle you could and you would
find well sort of by definition
everything is is invariant
so
when you take the intersection at this
point of course it's it's still empty
but now let's start to perform
interventions and say since the graph is
unknown at this point we don't have a
better idea than just performing
interventions at random
so say the first intervention
uh you perform x on x4
what happens is that all sets that
contain x4 to drop out so are no longer
invariant
but when we look at the remaining
invariant sets
and check what is our icp estimate it's
still empty
then we
continue to collect data this time we
intervene on on x3
and this time in fact this
did not help at all so the invariant
sets are exactly the same as in previous
iteration
then we continue intervening on x1 so
now all the sets that contained x1 drop
out so they're no longer invariant
um but unfortunately we're still unlucky
and the intersection
still needs an
an empty intersection as a final
estimate
so then the last step we finally
intervene on x0 and now this time
we end up with the estimate uh s-hat
being equal to x0
and this corresponds then to also to
s-star
but now of course the natural question
is whether we actually needed all these
environments to to arrive at that final
estimate or whether um with different
environments this uh
would have been uh easier or so if we
would have achieved the
the true estimate faster
and
i mean wouldn't you now also have this
issue that it's
inference after selection and
um
okay but let's see what happens if we if
we chose uh a different um
set of environments we first start out
again with this one but then this time
we um intervene on phonics zero again so
with those two environments we now
directly arrive at at the
at the true uh
the correct estimate even though the the
invariant sets we have now here are with
uh
much more than in the previous example
but for our icp estimate that's
understand that does not uh
doesn't that doesn't matter
um so in that sense some
environments are more informative than
others here now in the context of of
running icp and and getting a good
estimate for our star
uh so
then in this scenario where we do have
the option to to intervene on covariates
um we we ask ourselves okay how do we
select informative experiments is there
any sort of signal we can exploit um to
not do this at random but do this
potentially in a bit smarter way
so then the question is okay what what
is an informative intervention
so since our downstream goal is to
eventually run icp and estimate the
parent
we say that informative intervention is
the one after which the largest number
of parents appear in the estimate
so now this context is our our
definition for an informative
intervention
so then something one can show quite
easily as if you directly intervene on a
parent then it appears on all invariant
sets
and here i should point out and this is
where you have to be a bit more precise
so this is a
population statement in a sense that
this assumes sort of no testing errors
so of course in practice when you run
this on a small sample size
you might have testing errors that then
mean that this does not
happen
in the population setting of course it
would mean
since we have this result i just need to
intervene on everything once and i'm
done because then i have intervene on
all the parents
and then the intersection will then
give me the the parents exactly
but then in finite samples unfortunately
it's not that easy when you have small
sample sizes and potentially also not
very strong interventions
then due to the statistical testing that
underlies it
um you need often many more
interventions than just intervening on
everything once
um so now due to so this this
observation we treat interventions as
parents as maximally informative
but here i should also say there's a
caveat that for certain graph structures
it would actually be better to say
intervene on ancestors that are freed up
the graph and if i do that i might
actually as a result of that one
interventions have multiple parents that
appear in my icp estimate
so in that sense directly intervening on
parents is not always optimal but it
will depend on the graph structure and
since the graph structure is unknown
it is hard to detect these cases in in
practice
so now the the key idea here is that we
can actually look at how these invariant
sets sort of behave as we add
interventions
and they have properties that we can
exploit for for selecting experiments
so one thing is that parents appear on
at least half of all invariant sets at
any stage so no matter what the
environments are and no matter whether i
intervened on a parent or not
so we can always check sort of these
these ratios so how often a certain
covariate appears on these invariant
sets
and
hence we would not intervene on
variables that appear less often because
we know that these are not not parents
and our goal is to intervene on parents
even though of course
we don't know which exact which queries
are the parents
and then another simple thing you can
exploit is that look at the marginal
distribution of y
and if that is invariant under set of
environments
then you know that none of the
interventions in that set of
environments were performed upstream of
the response
so from that we derive so-called empty
set strategy which says that if after an
intervention the marginal distribution
of y is invariant
then we would discard the intervention
target from future interventions so we
would not intervene on that variable
again
and so in practice for this we would
assume we have some observational
environment where we know there are no
interventions and then we can always
contrast that environment and then take
the latest
intervention so then
evaluate this based on these two
environments
and
also here so this empty set strategy
only makes sense in a finite
sample setting due to what i said
previously
that in the population setting we don't
need to intervene on any variable twice
anyways because intervening on
everything once is sufficient so this
empty set strategy is really something
that
that is only useful in a finite sample
context
but we will see that there it's actually
fairly effective
it's not a difficult proof but i think
there's uh yeah i don't have a very good
question
um also what i should say so these
results of this
this um property about the parents
um
it's it's fairly general sometimes the
graphical notion so we don't need
parametric assumptions at this point
even though the results i will show
later on are based on the linear section
and also stop one catch to this so this
is true for parents but that's also true
for answers more generally so
unfortunately this does not give us like
as much signal as
first of all
um
but um
we can't deduct from it that variables
that have a ratio of or like that appear
less sometimes but those aren't parents
or not answers more generally
um
yes
so then uh
we have these different strategies so
the first two i just mentioned and then
the last one is also sort of a natural
thing you might consider in the setting
that you say oh i try to estimate the
markov blanket and i pick intervention
targets from within the markov blanket
and then so we have these three
different strategies which would in
general just narrow down the possible
intervention targets so the possible
covariates we can
intervene on and then we can of course
also combine these and which would
further shrink the the positive pool of
possible intervention targets
so
when you speak of a policy it would be
some combination of these three as of
base strategies
so then these are some experimental
results so and each of these plots on
the y-axis we show the average car
similarity and then the x-axis we showed
the intervention numbers also the number
of environments
and then we do this for different sample
sizes so just 10 observations per
intervention or environment then 100 and
1000
and so
the
the different lines of all the different
so combinations of the of the strategy i
presented and then the solid red line is
just the random strategy
so this would be the sort of the the one
we would would like to beat
and here we observed like for small
sample sizes that one is so maybe
surprisingly hard to beat because these
strategies are introduced right they all
rely on estimating some quantity
with small synthesizers you will make
errors there
which the random strategy um of course
is not subject to
but now even for for this so a few
observations per interventions you see
that this this empty set strategy is
actually quite effective at
um
as of obtaining a large average
carcinoma literally
fairly fairly quickly
and also for the other uh sample sizes
it's i'd say the one that is of most
robust across the large number of
settings
what was initially a little bit
surprising to us the sets of exploiting
the markov it does not uh work better
and that is really due to the estimation
errors we get so
if we
like focus here so for instance in the
right plot and the first number of
interventions so all the
strategy or policies that exploit the
markov bank and so initially sort of
have the best performance
and that comes because sort of the
estimate of the markov blanket will
typically contain some parents but not
not necessarily all of them
so then we quickly intervene on these
parents and they end up in our estimate
so so we we have those
but then we also miss some in the
estimate and we will never intervene on
these and then as a result they will
never end up in our final estimate
so that's why unfortunately um relying
on the mark of blanket is in that sense
good if you say have only a small budget
for interventions then you could say
okay if you know beforehand you can just
perform very few interventions
then this may be something you would
want to do but if you can perform a
larger number of interventions these
estimation errors you will make there
will will hurt you sort of down the road
and here are some details i did not
mention so this is like typically p is
so number of variables it's like it's 11
or 12 in this example
so it's it's still a fairly
small problem because that you have to
perform these
all these uh tests for the different
subsets
um and this is average i think over 300
uh different structural equation models
uh then finally one comparison with the
competing method so it's the bayesian
approach abcd and maybe at the outset i
should say so these methods are not
perfectly comparable because they have
different strengths and weaknesses in
different settings
so for instance abcd would require a
large observation sample
but then the following
samples so the interventional ones
could be quite small so it could be as
small as one observation per experiment
whereas for this active version of icp
we need we don't need a large
observation sample but we need sort of
say a reasonable number of data points
per experiment
so here we try to establish a sensible
sort of middle ground for these two
methods
but but in that sense in different
settings you would able to see somewhat
different behavior
so what we're gonna plot here so the
left plot is the same as you saw on the
previous slide
so average the car similarly as a
function of the intervention number
and then on the right hand side we we
got the family-wise error rate which is
you defined as the empirical probability
that the estimate you get so the s-head
is not a subset of a star
so starting on the left what we see is
that so in terms of power sort of abcd
starts out higher so with just very few
interventions it gives us a higher car
similarity but then it somewhat plateaus
towards the end and does not approach
one as we perform more interventions
and for
aicp and contrast you see at the
beginning we we start off with zero so
due to this conservativeness
of the construction of the estimate but
then sort of the power increases as we
add these these environments and finally
we also like we reach a number very
close to close to one
and what we see on the right hand side
when you look at the family voice error
rate that indeed for a icp so this is
controlled as it should be by
construction
but for
abcd you see that uh so it's not so you
do get uh false positives
and it does not get rid of these false
positives as you as you add intervention
so this is also then why we don't reach
the
perfect jacquard seminary on the left
so
depending on the context of what is the
cost in your setting for false positives
versus uh
false negatives you may not want to
choose one method over the other
so to conclude so
what we saw like causal models are
invariant and generalized
and invariant models with respect to
some set of observed environments
are potentially causal
and heterogeneity plays a key role in
the performance of invariant cause of
predictions and the power you get
and here some informatives as some
environments are more informative than
others and in aicp we collect these
informative new environments by
observing which models
are invariant given the current
environments and how that
changes
and this may help to find the causal
model more quickly also depending on
sample size and intervention strengths
so um
seeing like yeah what power you have and
how much the setting challenges the
statistical testing you do underneath
so that's also um maybe common about the
the different um
performance of these methods
um
so for the this ratio statistics really
we sort of
use all the test results so errors in
those individual tests will
sort of bias that that statistic and
hence that sense heard sort of the
selection process
similarly this
empty set strategy we um
we formulated also relies on on the test
result
and and may then also make uh make
mistakes
um there may be one point of discussion
at the end so
icp when you run it it does not require
knowledge of the intervention locations
so
that on the one hand it makes it robust
of target effects as long as they don't
affect y itself
and in this framework you could also say
you combine existing environments with
where the intervention targets are
unknown
with more these actively collected ones
in this framework
but on the other hand we also discard
information we now have
for these actively collect environments
right there we do know where we
intervened
and and this is not really exploited in
the underlying methods so
potentially there's still room to to
improve this procedure by by building in
this this knowledge more explicitly
and with that i'd like to thank you for
your attention and yeah happy to take
any more questions if there are any
how would you
use the active icp method for learning
the
entire graph so if you're not just
interested in the parents
i guess there
that's a good question i mean right now
even what you could always do is the
same as to write the the non-active one
that you did do this for every note
um
[Music]
i mean i guess
my agency you cannot do so much more
because right then the target always
changes right so you always have a
different
uh
regression problem you would have to
consider and hence um
it does not seem like you could benefit
so much from the results you already
collected
um in the active setting
i mean you can
i mean you can of course sort of
leverage the
the the collected data but you would
have to rerun the models
so
and then
how the collected data i mean it's
probably something you should exploit
but that something like not really
collected for that other target
so it seems like yeah you could probably
gain something but um
i would imagine for some parts of the
graph also it may not help you much
especially for very large graphs right
so
we try to do something really local
stuff around y
so if you're very large grams
might not help you so much
but it also depends a lot on the express
structure
yeah thanks talk um i guess i have two
questions they're quick the first one
was about
uh in the regular icp you have this kind
of
statistical guarantee that you're you'll
include the right set of parents high
probability and you have confidence
intervals so can you comment on how that
whether you have anything like that in
this activity
since we so the strategies that we
formulate are just for the environment
collection and then you just take the
environment and run icp on top so all of
that carries
and over another quick question i guess
was about you mentioned
the application to
um
this un health data
where your environments were different
continents
and can you comment on
so most of the examples are in settings
where there's an actual intervention and
that's one in which i guess you're
assuming that there's kind of it's kind
of like an intervention because it's
exogenous
is there any
is there any advice about how how that
should work i guess in these
observational settings
so i think there's sort of not an
immediate connection but i think in some
settings at least sort of these
considerations and these sort of small
results we derived here to maybe sort of
inform the choice how you define or form
the environment in more observational
settings that you sort of you know try
to reason a bit more okay is this
something that acts
upstream of these other covariates so
maybe when you have some background
knowledge it might sort of inform how
exactly you would define the
environments
but yeah how much background noise you
have to depend on the application
i mean another sort of related point to
this is
so from the results right we we saw okay
we want to intervene on parents because
then
at least in the population setting it
means we that we don't have that parent
in our estimate but in the finite sample
setting often that does not happen we
actually have to be multiple times until
we finally have enough power that this
happens
and sometimes it's actually quite
effective to intervene on a child
because it will then rule out a number
of sets that were previously still
invariant
and i think
that i mean it's more empirical
observation but i think in this
sort of un settings right we define some
environment variables and you somehow
need them to be upstream in the graph to
sort of make the testing problems work
but now i think
yeah maybe one can also bring in this
additional observation that sometimes if
you intervene on a child it will help in
in terms of ruling out in various senses
it will in turn help you estimate when
you take the intersection of things
um but then how exactly you would do
that i think that that is open
thank you
can you so so one part that's not
clicking it in my head is this result
that you had with the markup blankets
right and so
um to me it seems that look if i have a
ton of observational data then surely i
should be using that to somehow get like
a rough structure on the graph and then
not worry about things that are far
um so i think yes so an important sort
of point is are you a scenario where you
have a lot of observational data or are
you in a scenario where maybe sort of
all of these different environments are
for a small size
because then right you would have to
estimate the markov language from a
small sample and then you have these
errors
and i think you're right that write the
larger n the better our estimate should
get but even so like this the largest we
show here n is one thousand even there
so for many graphs which will say
observe this this behavior that yes
initially it helps because it will
directly intervene on the parents we
have included but there's still many
cases where we
where we leave them out and i mean we
try to play this with sort of the
i mean estimated by the lassos we played
with the regular parameter but it was
not sort of as straightforward of just
saying like okay regularize less and
then we will always have an overestimate
so so unfortunately we could not get it
to work better
and i think it's a brilliant line it's
also the observation that um from
estimating the pdac from from
observation data empirically for for say
medium or small sample sizes
unfortunately does not work as reliable
as as one offer what would hope it to
work so i think it's a bit of a similar
uh sort of thing going on here
thanks